naja was mich ja Dauer beschäftigt ist
irgendwie der Zustand dieser
Ampelkoalition und da ist sozusagen die
neueste spannende Umdrehung das jetzt
also der Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck verkündet hat und zwar
offensichtlich ohne seinen Amtskollegen
Christian Linder von der FDP auf dem
Finanzministerium auch nur zu fragen das
ist also keine Auswirkung auf den
Strompreis habe wenn die Atomkraftwerke
vom Netz gehen und das war ja nun nicht
die erste Runde in Sachen Atomkraft also
die Grünen hatten da ja auch eine
Beschlusslage und waren also es lag ihn
sehr viel daran dass man insgesamt
aussteigt also möglichst schnell es gab
einen anderslautenden Expertenrat also
verschiedene Experten haben gesagt macht
das in dieser Situation lieber nicht
dann hat man sich geeinigt zwei
Atomkraftwerke bis zum nächsten Frühjahr
dann brauchte es ein Machtwort des
Kanzlers nun also das dritte
Atomkraftwerk auch bis zum Frühjahr
laufen zu lassen in einer der schwersten
energiekrisen die wir je erlebt haben
und das ist natürlich sozusagen jetzt
ein Aufreger es ist aber im Grunde ja
nur ein Symptom für eine Koalition die
eigentlich überhaupt nicht zusammen